the more you think about it the more it
seems really likely that Jackie will be
the first human meat that the yellow
jackets crash victims eat based on the
ritualistic nature and the way it looks
like they've done it before it's safe to
say that they've already crossed the
line into cannibalism by the time they
kill the pit girl considering what we've
learned about them as characters though
it's hard to imagine them getting from
where they are right now to cold-blooded
murder they should all have a shared
secret and eating Jackie first would
bind them together while it could also
set the stage for factionalization and
the escalation from eating what they
have on hand to hunting prey also
there's a scene in season one where
Jackie gives Sean the last of her
rations because she's hungry can totally
see how this could be a sign of things
to come not having enough food could
mean losing the baby for Shauna and in
that situation wouldn't Jackie prefer to
be a sacrifice it's dark but it should
be fun to see how it unfolds